[Music]
on this sunday night
the deadly halloween attack in quebec
the alleged attacker in costume carrying
a sword
randomly stabbing all the citizens of
our city are
mooring this today two people are dead
five others
injured the investigation into the death
of a canadian soldier
during a military exercise plus america
prepares for a legal battle over
election results and canada's silver
cross mother
i feel like a piece of my soul has been
ripped out of my body her
fight for veterans rights
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us it was a terrifying halloween night
in quebec city
police say a man dressed in a costume
armed with a sword
targeted people at random two people
were killed
five others injured the violence
occurred in the city's historic district
the victims were located at four sites
including
near the famous chateau frontenac the
suspect managed to elude authorities for
nearly three hours
until he was finally rested in the
vicinity of the port
the 24 year-old is now facing two
charges of first-degree murder
as well as attempted murder as michael
couture reports police say there are no
apparent links to terror groups
or any religious ideology
police describe it as a night of horror
officials say at around 10
30 saturday a man dressed in a medieval
costume brandishing a japanese sword
pulled up at the iconic chateau front
neck in quebec city
and began a stabbing rampage
it's shocking on halloween and with a
full moon
says this resident of old quebec who
lives near the crime scenes
following a two and a half hour manhunt
police finally apprehended the 24 year
old suspect
a kilometer away near quebec city's old
port
but that was after he allegedly killed
two quebec residents and injured
five others police don't believe the
attacks were motivated
by politics or religion according to our
primary information
nothing indicates that the suspect would
have acted
for motivations other than personal
the suspect is carl juan it's believed
he lives in this apartment block 20
minutes north of montreal
heavily armed police officers spent the
day here looking for clues pointing to
why he drove nearly three hours
to allegedly commit such acts acts that
bring back
horrific memories of the mosque shooting
in the provincial capital
nearly four years ago it reminded us all
of the tragedy of the
29th of january 2017
when six people six of our people in
quebec city died
police say according to a medical source
five years ago jahwal
allegedly talked about carrying out such
acts
and while the police chief didn't make
the connection to mental health concerns
quebec's mayor did mental health is the
biggest
security that's a challenge
for the future of our
own cities or of the country as
officials grapple with what went wrong
there remains a realization that
pandemic restrictions
essentially shut down that part of
quebec city
meaning saturday's rampage could have
been a lot worse
mike lacrouter global news
the military police are investigating
the death of a canadian soldier killed
during a training exercise
in alberta corporal james joy was an
army reservist from bc
the 29 year old was shot friday night
while taking part in live
fire training at cfb brain rate he died
in hospital yesterday
troy joined the canadian armed forces in
2016.
both joe biden and donald trump are
using the final stretch of the campaign
to woo
undecided voters today biden focused on
pennsylvania
while president trump went on a campaign
blitz in michigan
iowa north carolina georgia and florida
a new poll puts the democrats ahead but
as jennifer johnson reports
that doesn't guarantee a win late in the
game but still
fighting to keep his job u.s president
donald trump is campaigning in five
states sunday dissecting the country
from michigan to miami
under my leadership our economy is now
growing at the fastest rate
ever recorded 33.1
democratic presidential candidate joe
biden is targeting swing state
pennsylvania
with two rallies in philadelphia we need
every single
one of you to get out and vote on
tuesday
my message is simple pennsylvania is
critical in this election running mates
mike pence and kamala harris are both
courting crucial votes in north carolina
and georgia
as early voting continues to shatter
records close to 92 million people have
already cast their ballots
meanwhile a new nbc news wall street
journal poll shows biden holds a
double-digit lead over the president
52 to 42 percent among registered voters
we're hopeful very hopeful but americans
may not know who their next president is
tuesday night
states like north carolina and
pennsylvania can count votes several
days
after the election cities are taking
precautions
to prevent any violence we're not going
to tolerate them
coming for the property the product or
the people
the coven 19 crisis is still looming
over the election
that new poll shows 57 percent of
americans disapprove
of the way the president has handled the
pandemic i think december is probably
going to be our toughest month but when
you look at what's happening at states
right now you're seeing accelerating
spread
somber months ahead as a new stanford
university study
shows 18 of trump's rallies where
attendees
rarely wear masks may have led to over
30 thousand cases of covet 19
and 700 deaths jennifer johnson global
news
washington our washington bureau chief
jackson proskow joins us now
jackson let's talk about the lawyering
up and the legal preparations already
underway
to contest the election results and it
isn't even voting day
good evening to you robin this is all
because president trump is pushing the
view that the election results must be
known on november 3rd
even though historically that hasn't
always happened and even though states
are given
weeks to certify their results and
finish counting
and they've already warned it's going to
take extra time to do that count because
there are so many male
imbalance but here's what's happening
across the country in places like harris
county texas that's where houston is
republicans have gone to court to try
and have 125 000 ballots
that have already been cast thrown out
these were ballots cast
at drive-in voting sites in pennsylvania
and wisconsin officials are already
preparing for inevitable court
challenges
and they say they're going to segregate
any late arriving mail-in ballots
they'll put them off to the side
just in case there's a later court
ruling that results in them being thrown
out
trump's strategy in particular seems to
rely on the courts to sway this in his
favor
but it only works if this is close but i
can tell you that if republicans are
fighting things in texas
typically a republican stronghold that
tells you they're worried about the
big picture here robin that's not a good
sign for them and
also you have to keep in mind that the
way the election results unfold on
election night could swing wildly you
might see
things sway toward trump is the early
count comes in and then later as mail-in
ballots are pro
processed it could swing back toward
biden so be
wary of anyone trying to make an early
victory claim on tuesday
jackson jennifer johnson mentioned the
latest poll but really
isn't it still an election that's too
close to call
it is i know it's counter-intuitive to
talk about this being a nail-biter when
you're also talking about a 10-point
spread but when you dial down to the
state by state level
the key states that matter things are
much much closer there
and really we're left with a couple of
issues one is the big
unknowns out there we don't know what
the impact of that early
unprecedented turnout is going to be we
don't know about all these mail-in
ballots whether they'll be counted
and at the end of the day we don't know
if there will be some sort of disruption
in some
areas on election day like violence on
the polls which is a major concern here
as well
at the same time we also know that it
can still be anybody's race there are
pathways for both men here so
while things look better on paper for
joe biden right now
make no mistake donald trump still has
paths that could let him eke out a win
here
jackson prosecuting washington thanks
jackson
there's no doubt canadians will be
watching the results tuesday night and
wondering what the final
outcome will mean for this country a new
ipsos poll conducted exclusively for
global news
found 69 percent of canadians feel a joe
biden victory would be good for canada
22 percent would prefer a donald trump
reelection
overall 60 percent of people surveyed
worry about potential violence
if trump loses for more on what the
canadian government is doing to prepare
for the outcome of the election
let's bring in our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson mercedes what are you
hearing in the halls of power in our
capital
robin a senior government source told me
that planning for this election
began much earlier than previous u.s
elections
as you can imagine those preparations
have been intense
with a flurry of briefings and threat
assessments
the real wild card in all of this of
course
is u.s president donald trump for months
he has said
the only way he can lose is if there's
fraud and so americans
and canadians are bracing for the
possibility of a contested result
i'm not as alarmist as some people i
don't assume he's going to hold on to
his desk and refuse to leave
but i do think there could be turmoil uh
if he thinks confusion and chaos
can help him hang on can help affect
recounts and contests
i think there's every prospect he'll
engage in multiple sources told me that
the canadian government will do
everything it can to stay out of u.s
politics
and the line of fire until there is a
clear result
in the meantime we may see some civil
unrest or the possibility of violence
south of the border
and that could have repercussions up
here in canada one scenario that is
always a nightmare scenario for canada
is the issue of security threats coming
from canada
crossing the canadian-american border
and reaching the u.s
the fear on our side is always that the
response on the american side will be to
close the border
which economically would be devastating
for us
a former senior canadian intelligence
official told me that agencies here in
canada
will keep a close eye on border states
like michigan and
washington still most experts agree
that american institutions will
withstand whatever chaos
we may see in the weeks to come the
trudeau government says that it will be
ready to work with whomever
ultimately wins the white house robin
mercedes stevenson in ottawa thanks
mercedes
turning now to culver 19 america's top
infectious diseases expert isn't holding
back
in a new interview with the washington
post dr anthony fauci
contradicted the president's claim that
the u.s is rounding the turn
on the virus fauci says the u.s could
not be positioned more poorly in this
pandemic
he warns americans are in for a whole
lot of hurt
in the weeks ahead trump is facing more
intense criticism from the biden
campaign over his handling of the
pandemic
former president barack obama says
thousands of american lives could have
been saved
if the u.s response was more like
canada's
if we had handled this pandemic like
canada did 140
000 of our fellow americans might still
be alive today
that's that's that's a sign of how much
leadership in the white house matters
here's how canada is doing compared to
the us when it comes to coronavirus
deaths
in the u.s there have been roughly 70
deaths per 100 000 people
in canada there have been about 27
deaths
per 100 000 people canada may be faring
better than the us
in this pandemic but in some parts of
this country case numbers are rising
fast
both quebec and ontario reported more
than 950 new infections today
there were more than 300 new cases in
manitoba and 74
in saskatchewan further west case
numbers aren't reported on the weekend
coming up the message from seniors don't
diminish
their vote
trump and biden have focused their
campaigns with one specific segment of
the population in mind
seniors they were a very important part
of trump's win in 2016
and the demographic is growing tonight
our mike armstrong has a look
at their role it may be a good thing
this election is wrapping up
the frustration here in cambridge ohio
is building
pop into the local republican office and
they'll tell you how their donald trump
stand up
lost its head girl walks up looks like
she wants to take a picture and she tore
the head off the
multiple cameras well a few blocks away
james love has a story about his biden
signs being stolen
three and counting it it's not so much
to sign it's a principle
now this county went to donald trump in
2016 in a landslide
but even here where over and over we
were told this
this is definitely donald trump country
even the most ardent trump supporters
admit
some seniors have been rubbed the wrong
way because they don't like his
personality
by his style it does rub on the wrong
way because my best friend hates him for
it
and she was going to vote opposite
because of it and i said
you can't do that county officials here
empty the early ballot drop-off box a
couple of times a day
well when they start counting the
ballots tuesday polls predict a
substantial shift by seniors
in 2016 trump won seniors nationally by
seven percent
going into tuesday's vote he's losing
that group to joe biden
according to some polls by 10 percent
while seniors are vital because seniors
vote
political scientist michael binder says
as a group seniors are the most likely
to show up at the polls
and they're growing americans 65 and
over were
21 of eligible voters in 2016. they're
23 percent this time
and in some states even more we're a
greying country
they're going to be 30 of the electorate
in florida which is a
crucial swing state seniors will be
first
we make seniors first right trump
speeches for weeks have included a
promise
seniors will be at the front of the line
when a vaccine is ready but
he's also mocked biden as a nursing home
resident
and claimed the virus affects virtually
nobody
who was he talking about when he said it
affects virtually
nobody he was talking about america's
seniors
he was talking about you mr trump has
shown that he's callous
back in cambridge james love says
trump's basically written seniors off
well if poll numbers hold the shift by
seniors could be the biggest factor in a
biden win
in fact if biden's lead with older
voters hits double
digits some pollsters say it could mean
not just most
swing states go to him but all of them
mike armstrong global news cambridge
ohio
still ahead this year's silver cross
mother
every year the royal canadian legion
picks a silver cross mother to lay a
wreath
on behalf of the families who have lost
her son or daughter
in the service of their country this
year's remembrance day ceremony will
look a bit different because of the
pandemic
but debbie sullivan will be there and
she hopes canadians will take
time on november 11th to honor those
like her son navy lieutenant chris
saunders
who made the ultimate sacrifice ross
lord reports
when life comes to a sudden end just as
it's blossoming
there's a particular sadness 16 years
after navy lieutenant chris saunders
died
his mother debbie has never been the
same i feel like a piece of my soul has
been
ripped out of my body we're not supposed
to
outlive our children he's my son and i
don't ever want him to be forgotten
so i speak his name daily i talk to him
daily
chris saunders died in a fire on board a
navy submarine in 2004.
hmcs shakutami was on route from
scotland to halifax
to begin service in the canadian fleet
two other crew members were badly
injured
at age 32 saunders had started a career
as a combat systems engineer
he was married with two children to keep
her son's memory alive
debbie has been named the royal canadian
legion's
national silver cross mother she's
attending remembrance day ceremonies in
ottawa
limited by the pandemic but still going
ahead
they did tell me that it would be a lot
smaller they did tell me that there
would be
a lot of wreaths that were pre-laid
ahead of time but that i would actually
be
laying a reef social distancing of
course
and they assured me they would keep me
very safe
some days are still a struggle you know
certain songs come on
and stuff but tough moments that arrive
out of the blue yeah just different
different songs that remind me of him
she takes pride in tributes like the
elementary school named after chris
in his hometown of quispam sisk new
brunswick this is my favorite picture of
him
he's on board a ship he's looking out to
see it's it's like he's
very thoughtful and thinking in the
background
is him in his football uniform and on
the other side is him
uh mountain biking and he looks ruggedly
handsome there
well of course he did not be proud of
that of course he is
you know he's got his mama's eyes
[Laughter]
finding positives in the lingering
effects of tragedy
ross lord global news clifton royal new
brunswick
up next a stark reminder of those who've
lost their lives
to a vicious virus
the pandemic has added another layer of
anxiety to the already tense u.s
presidential election
and on a patch of grass a few kilometers
from the white house
the human toll of what's unfolded over
the past nine months
is laid out in long lines of white flags
donna friesen is reporting from
washington this week and what she
discovered
is a memorial reminiscent of war
it is stark it is simple and the scale
of it is overwhelming
i tell you it breaks my heart
because each one of these flags is a
person
more than 229 thousand white flags
one for each life loss to kovid 19 in
the u.s
planted in rows like a wartime cemetery
it's the work of artist suzanne brennan
ferstenberg
in mid-august i read a washington post
headline
that said government official says 170
000
deaths is just a statistic and i thought
oh my god
this can't be it took her months to get
approval to do this on the parade ground
of the washington d.c
national guard armory and what started
small
just keeps on growing edna tempener
volunteers
to be here i think i've planted about 5
000 flags
we've been failed we've been failed by
our leaders in the middle of the field
we spot this young woman christine
uncles
planting a flag for her father it was
heartbreaking
and it was just very overwhelming i
didn't
expect to see so many flags i knew the
number was high but it was just
to actually visually see it was just
absolutely disturbing
she was by her dad's side john when he
died of covid19 in april
he was 69. it crushes me to know that
there's so many more out there and my
dad was one of them
what does she think of how president
trump has handled the pandemic
i think it's awful i think he handled
this absolutely poorly
and i very much hold his action and
reaction to this
fully responsible for all of these
deaths
the white flag says ferstenberg
represent innocence
not surrender i felt compelled to make
the number
experienceable if you will
it's often artists who can best
interpret the moment
we are in we're divided by ideology
we're divided by race we're divided by
socio-economic factors
the one thing that we can unify about is
grief because we've all lost something
if people haven't lost a loved one
they've lost jobs they've lost
businesses
they've lost educational opportunities
the loss
in the u.s has been tragic
just immense and so if we can't agree on
anything else we can at least unite in
our grief
and in our mourning that we are still in
the midst of this tragedy
donna friesen global news washington
and that is global national for this
sunday i'm robin gill
tonight we leave you with last night's
full moon scene from bc
thanks for watching good night
[Music]
you